muy bien hablemos del problema número 17
o que fue uno de los problemas número 17
y estamos cerca de acabar esta sección
número 5 del examen número 7 vamos a
ponernos a ver si lo puedo acabar en
este vídeo dice la suma de 3 entre los
impares consecutivos la suma de tres
enteros impares consecutivos es 111 eso
nos dice la primera frase después dice
si n representa el menor de estos
enteros
cuál es la ecuación que representa el
enunciado anterior ok a ver lo primero
que nos dice es que es el menor de estos
enteros entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí n
es el menor de ellos pero son tres
enteros impares consecutivos
así que si n es menor de ellos el que le
sigue
va a ser n más y fíjate que no es n 1
porque si en este caso n valdría no sé 3
n más uno sería 4
y 4 no sería impar para que cumpla que
sean impares el siguiente le tenemos que
sumar dos tienes tres entonces en más
dos tendría que ser un 5 y entonces
también sería un número impar y justo
aquí está la clave de este problema
recuerda que si tenemos tres enteros
consecutivos y no te dicen que sean
impares o pares entonces te tomas n y
después n 1 y así etcétera etcétera pero
si te dicen que son impares es muy
importante ir de dos en dos en el n 2 y
entonces el que sigue sería n más 31 de
hecho más dos en más 4 perdón
justo lo que estoy diciendo y en eso me
equivoco perdón perdón perdón dice n n 2
y n más 47 por ejemplo vale 3 entonces
en más 2 vale 5 tiene más 4 vale 7 y
está perfecto los tres son impares y
además son consecutivos en limpiar
consecutivo de 13 5 y el de 5 y 7
entonces vamos bien hasta aquí recuerda
que tienes que ir de dos en dos y me
dicen que la suma de
3 111 pero espera cuánto vale la suma de
estos tres si yo me quisiera tomar la
suma de estos tres me quedaría en
masséna más en lo cuales tres n y
después me quedaría dos más cuatro lo
cual es 63 106 es la suma de estos tres
enteros impares ahora eso por una parte
porque por otra parte me dicen que esta
suma tiene que ser igual a 111 y bueno
justo aquí está la respuesta a este
problema lo que me dicen es cuál es la
ecuación aquí está la ecuación en
términos de nm que representa a la frase
anterior la suma de tres de los
consecutivos sin parece 111 eso se ve de
esta manera ahora tú puedes obtener el
valor de n si quieres de aquí podríamos
restar 6 ambos lados de esta ecuación y
después dividir todo entre 3 y así
obtener el valor de n pero lo bueno es
que este problema solamente me pide la
ecuación y la ecuación es 3 n 6 igual a
111 que es el inciso d
ya está aquí el problema número 17 y
vamos a resolver ahora el problema
número 18 que no creo que me quepa aquí
así que borremos el pizarrón vamos a
trabajar con el problema número 18 y
tiene una figura parecida a ésta a ver
si me sale
tengo una figura más o menos algo así me
agrada ok viendo esta figura
tenemos lo siguiente fíjate bien tengo a
que es la distancia que hay de aquí de
aquí hasta no sé hasta por acá es 2
después tengo un pedazo con una
distancia de b después tengo que de aquí
hasta acá hasta acá vale otra vez 2
después por aquí tengo un pedazo de bem
después de aunque la distancia que de
aquí hasta que otra vez vale 2 y después
aquí tengo una distancia de b y después
de una distancia de 2 y así se sigue y
sigue y se sigue ok ahora me dicen la
figura siguiente muestra la parte de un
círculo que tienen una circunferencia de
ok eso es importante la circunferencia o
el perímetro de este círculo es 45 45 ok
y después dice si las longitudes de 2 y
de b se siguen alternando durante toda
la circunferencia 2 b2 b2 b2 b2 vea si
se siguen alternando ok y este patrón se
repite 18 veces ok eso es muy importante
este patrón se va a repetir en 18 veces
cuál es la medida en grados de cada arco
de medida
ok a ver dejando un rastro de aquí
primero qué te parece si sacamos el
valor de b es decir de la longitud de
este arco y para sacar la longitud de
este arco a lo que quiero que te des
cuenta es que la circunferencia lo que
nosotros sabemos es que el perímetro de
esta circunferencia es igual a 45 bueno
esto por una parte pero por otra parte
también podemos ver este mismo perímetro
sumando longitudes de arco de dos
longitudes de arco de longitud de arco
de 2
de algo debe cuantas veces bueno pues
aquí vamos a utilizar lo que me dice el
problema el problema dice lo siguiente
este patrón se repite exactamente 18
veces es decir que hay 18 veces que se
repite el 2 y también hay 18 veces que
se repite de este patrón 2 más bien se
repite 18 veces y bueno esto tiene que
ser igual a la longitud completa de la
circunferencia es decir el perímetro y
esto es igual a 45 y de aquí ya está
bien padre porque podemos despejar el
valor de b la longitud del arco b es
igual a quien bueno 18 por 2 es 36 36
más 18 ven esto es igual a 45 ok y de
equipo decir que 18 pm es igual a 45 36
lo cual es 9
ok tiene tiene sentido lógico y aquí me
va a quedar a 9 entre 18 lo cual por
cierto es un medio
es decir que ya sé cuánto vale la
longitud de este arco es un medio aquí
tengo un medio aquí tengo un medio y de
hecho esto se repite
cuántas veces 18 ok pero es que me
preguntan no es el valor de haber vamos
muy bien pero lo que me preguntan es
cuál es la medida en grados de cada arco
que tiene una longitud de arco de b ok
es decir que si yo tengo aquí el centro
a mi centro estaba como por aquí
ok pensamos que este es el centro yo lo
que quiero saber es cuánto mide la
longitud de arco que voy a dibujar de
justo ahorita cuánto mide la longitud de
algo cuando lo sabemos es un medio más
bien lo que quiero saber es cuánto mide
en grados esta apertura de aquí justo
atrás lo que voy es tras esta cantidad
de ángulos que le voy a llamar x y cómo
lo podemos obtener bueno se me ocurre
que podemos obtener x o ya serias con
una regla de tres si con una regla de
tres creo que sale de manera muy
sencilla por qué porque yo sé que darle
una vuelta entera a la circunferencia
son 360
es decir que 360 grados
me da una circunferencia de cuánto me da
una circunferencia de 45 de 45 unidades
voy a utilizar esto de aquí ahora eso
por una parte pero yo sé que la longitud
de este arco es un medio un médium y lo
que yo me pregunto es cuál es la medida
en grados de este ángulo o dicho de otra
manera cuántos grados tienen una
longitud de arco de un medio y aquí ya
tengo una regla de tres te das cuenta lo
único que necesitamos es multiplicar
este por este dividirlo entre este me va
a dar mi resultado este por éste entre
este y me dan el resultado ojo estoy
utilizando longitudes de circunferencia
yo sé qué 360 grados me dan un perímetro
de 45 unidades y yo sé y por otra parte
yo quiero saber cuántos ángulos me dan
una longitud de arco de un medio y
cuántos esto pues vamos a ver y aquí me
va a quedar que
x es igual a 360 360 por un medio todo
esto entre 45 x es igual a 360 por un
medio es lo mismo que 180 180 entre 45
ok x es igual a 45 más 45 es 90 90 más
90 es 180 es decir que cabe cuatro veces
cuatro veces pero como es una medida en
ángulos van a ser cuatro grados ok ya
tengo la respuesta de este problema este
problema me dice que cuando se cumpla el
patrón de 2 b2b durante toda la
circunferencia que tiene un perímetro de
45 entonces el arco que tiene una
longitud de arco de b es un arco de 4
grados justo esta apertura es de 4
grados y creo que tienen todo el sentido
lógico del mundo porque se repite 18
veces se va a repetir esto muchas veces
y recuerda que la suma de todos los
ángulos me tienen que dar 360 grados
ok espero que se haya entendido este
problema y no te estás confundiendo
bastante mejor bounds el problema
siguiente el problema número 19 déjame
tomar una nueva herramienta 19 dice
aunque por cierto espera el problema
anterior su respuesta es el inciso am y
de la anterior el inciso de inciso d del
17 inciso a del 18 y el 19
vamos a ver dice el costo del
mantenimiento de un cierto automóvil
aumenta cada año en un 10% ok eso es
importante aumenta cada año en un 10%
esto es lo que va a aumentar ok
carlos pago el primer año por el
mantenimiento de su automóvil 3000 pesos
el costo del mantenimiento del automóvil
dado por n años está dado por la
siguiente función y vamos a poner aquí
la función dice cdn cdn a ser que
depende de n porque en esos dos años es
igual a tres mil a tres mil y bueno esto
tiene toda la lógica del mundo porque
esto fue lo que pagó en un inicio carlos
esto que multiplica a x elevado a la n
iv lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale o
cuál es el valor de x yo lo que quiero
saber es cuál es el valor de x
ok a ver cómo lo podremos resolver
imagínate que el primer año yo sé que el
primer año
el costo fue de tres mil pesos ok esto
para el primer año así que le voy a
poner costo uno y para el segundo año el
costo aumenta a un 10 por ciento es
decir que voy a tener tres mil pesos
tres mil pesos ya esto le voy a aumentar
el 10% el 10% de tres mil pesos de tres
mil pesos ahora el 10% de tres mil pesos
esto es lo mismo que tres mil pesos son
estos de aquí más punto 1.1 que es el
10% de tres mil pesos o sea por tres mil
pesos muy bien pero de aquí puedo
actualizar tres mil esto es exactamente
lo mismo que tres mil tres mil que
multiplica a 1.1
punto 1
aquí estoy multiplicando por uno más
punto uno me queda 1.1 esto es lo que
voy a pagar de mantenimiento en el año 2
y ahora qué pasa con el año 3 ok y como
no me cabe que el tercer año
déjenme mover un poco la pantalla para
abajo y vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa
con el tercer año aunque deja militar
esto de aquí y estamos pensando en el
tercer año en el tercer año yo tengo que
a 4 hacer me costó bueno voy a hacer
esta cantidad de aquí esta va a ser mi
cantidad inicial 3000 por 1.1 ya esto le
voy a aumentar el 10 por ciento es decir
punto 1 que va a multiplicar a quien a
esta misma cantidad que va a multiplicar
a tres mil a tres mil que multiplica a
su vez a 1.1
y cuánto es esto bueno pues aquí podemos
factorizar justo a este mismo de aquí a
este mismo de aquí y esto me va a quedar
como esto va a ser igual a tres mil a
tres mil por 1.1 que multiplica a su vez
a 1.1 es este uno de aquí este 1.1 este
de aquí salen de este punto uno de aquí
y este uno de acá ok y entonces esto es
lo mismo que tres mil tres mil que
multiplica a 1.1 elevado al cuadrado y
creo que ya empieza a ver el patrón y es
más podemos escribir aquí que es lo que
pasa con el año número dos déjeme bajar
con el año número cuatro deje trabajar
un poco más la pantalla si yo me tomara
aquí que es lo que va a pasar con el
número cuatro
ya lo podemos intuir en el año número 4
esto es igual a tres mil tres mil por
1.1 elevado a la 3
es más para que no te confundas con el
año número 4 y 1 - qué te parece si
empezamos en
y ese subíndice 0 no voy a revisar un
poco para acá abajo déjenme subir la
pantalla un poco c 1 en lugar de segundo
voy a escribir ese subíndice 0 entonces
aquí va a poner 0 esto fue lo que costó
inicialmente después en el primer año en
el primer año esto lo voy a cambiar por
uno esto va a ser un 1 me va a quedar a
que en el primer año esto es igual a 3
mil por 1.1 elevado a la 1 ok ya se
empezaba el patrón 1 a la 1 en el
segundo año en el segundo año aquí me va
a quedar 3 mil elevado a la 2 esto es de
2 y esto está del lujo porque en el
segundo año me queda 3000 que es la
capital inicial por a 1.1 elevado a la
misma cantidad de años ahora qué pasa
déjeme bajar aquí subir la pantalla que
pasa en el tercer año bueno pues en el
tercer año yo voy a tener y ya vi el
patrón aquí voy a cambiar este por 3 y
me va a quedar 3000 por 1.1
al año yo quisiera sacar por ejemplo el
5 el 4 perdón en el cuarto año pues nos
va a quedar tres mil tres mil esto que
va a multiplicar a 1.1 elevado a la 4
bueno y todo esto para que a porque
recuerda que eso que nos preguntaban lo
que nos preguntaban es cuánto vale
déjame borrar aquí ok ya aparece un 3 lo
que nos preguntaban es cuánto vale x no
así que déjenme regresar la pantalla a
donde estábamos
al principio estábamos un poco más
arriba
ok problema número 19 ok sabemos por
aquí y dice si la cantidad que vamos a
pagar cn está dado por tres mil que
multiplica a equis elevado a la n
entonces cuánto vale x y fíjate aquí ya
podemos ver el patrón cuando estamos en
el año 1 cuando el nivel de 1
entonces elevamos a la primera potencia
ok y a quién elevamos a la primera
potencia a 1.1 cuando estamos en el año
2 cuando estamos en el año 2
el año lo llevamos a la segunda potencia
a 1.1 lo elevamos a la segunda potencia
ok
cuando estamos en el año 3 cuando
estamos en el año 3 a 1.1 lo llevamos la
tercera potencia en el año 4 a 1.1 la
elevamos en la cuarta potencia entonces
si no regresamos para acá cuando estoy
en el año n cuando estoy en el año n ok
qué va a pasar
bueno pues a 1.1 que es justa la tasa a
la que va a aumentar lo que yo voy a
pagar lo tenemos que llevar a la
potencia n es decir que se en en cn lo
podemos ver como tres mil tres mil que
multiplica a 1.1 elevado a la n en el
año jaime vamos a tener a 3.000 que va a
multiplicar a 1.1 esta es la tasa a la
que está creciendo lo que voy a pagar
esto elevado a la n por lo tanto pues ya
sabemos cuánto es x x debe de valer 1.1
para que se cumpla esta ecuación x debe
de ser igual a 1.1 y espero realmente no
haberte confundido mucho
así que para que no se haga esto más
pesado y más confuso creo que es todo lo
que voy a ver por este vídeo en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a resolver el
último problema el problema número 20
que por cierto tiene un paralelogramo ya
lo verás en el siguiente vídeo hasta la
próxima